are you friendly with Elizabeth Warren
at all I'm sure yeah you like her yeah
sure yeah I realize I think you two have
something in common
listen to this okay I'm watching
something with her on TV right he's
talking about how she met her husband
and she says I went up to him
so this nice guy I asked him out and
then after a few dates she turned to him
and said will you marry me now the
reason I say I I relate this to you
you're at Yale at this point you're
sitting there in the library maybe okay
right and you see that Bill Clinton a
guy you don't know right is staring at
you true I said if you're gonna keep
staring at me and I'm gonna keep staring
back we ought at least to know each
other's names I'm Hillary Rodham who are
you Wow
I met him were you nervous doing that no
mm-hmm oh my god no I would never have
the guts to even walk up to a woman so
the fact that you could do that but it
is a vulnerable position he could have
said to you I'm not staring at you get
lost
Yeah right he could've been ashamed at
night and then I would have known right
then he wasn't worth the time and he's
brilliant because he's at Yale Law right
right right I love a romance so then it
turns out he'd never been there but we
were actually in the same class oh why
was he going to class because he was
working on a political campaign to elect
somebody to something in Connecticut you
know politics was his first and foremost
love you had to be with the go getter I
mean you were a hard worker you also as
somebody who I thought was really smart
with a good heart I mean that's what I
was looking for and also had ambition oh
I had to have ambition
absolutely by definition if you've
gotten to be a law school you've got
some kind of ambition to do something
right anyway the last day of this class
he shows up in the class and come for
you apparently right and so we're
walking out and he said where you going
and I said well I'm going to register
for classes for next year because I'll
go too so we walk you know those are the
old days when you know you actually had
to use pencil and paper to register for
things right and so I stand in line I
get up to the register our bill and I
are talking our first real conversation
and the Registrar looks at because bill
what are you doing here you registered
this morning and so I knew that this was
all about you know getting to know me
right
then we went on about a five-hour date
where we took a walk we get to the Yale
art museum and they have a Mark Rothko
exhibit and I said oh I didn't I I
missed that I wish I had seen it because
the museum was closed because it was on
strike right so bill said what you
really like Rothko I said yeah I really
I really like him I've never seen his
stuff in person but I've seen you know
photographs he goes we'll stay here just
a minute so he goes off this guy I've
just met he comes back he introduces me
to this gentleman he goes this is you
know John the janitor and John the
janitor said he'll let us in if we pick
up all the trash on the lawn oh my god
what an operator pick up the trash yeah
and then we get to go in and see the
Rothko's and then we end up in the
sculpture garden this is a guy who is a
born people person and you know what he
says which is so important he says
everybody has a story and everybody
deserves to have their story told no
kiss at this point well we got there
eventually not at the museum not at the
museum I would have kissed them at the
museum oh now that's a busy well you
know I was just getting to know him
inside you know in those days we did
play a little hard to get
[Laughter]